I am called Chico moto the producer of
one to switch I am also the general
Hardware director for a Nintendo switch
itself one to switch lets you enjoy the
expressiveness of the joy con HD rumble
that was just introduced but at the same
time it's a brand new kind of game one
that mixes up new kinds of play that
haven't been seen before your typical
video game has you playing while looking
at some kind of screen right but one
source which can be played without
looking at any screen so then where
exactly do you look in the eyes of your
opponents you look directly into the
eyes of your opponent to play the game
when will your opponent move how will
they move are they just faking you look
into their eyes to read their next move
and then you get to see them do
something unexpected in other words one
source which isn't a game you play a
face in the screen it is a game that is
primarily played through face-to-face
interaction so you can bring Nintendo
switch to parties and after parties
indoors or outdoors any place people
gather or me and you simply one stand in
tandem switch up to grab the two joique
on three hand one to a friend and just
like that with these three steps the
place you're in becomes the game world
and everyone is ready for fun we're
creating one to switch to be a staple
for parties and to become an ice breaker
for all kinds of fun communication one
two switch features fun for everyone
gameplay made possible by the joke on
and it releases March 3rd alongside
Nintendo switch please look forward to
it thank you very much